Qu'est-ce qui sépare une décision bien intentionnée
de la censure ?
Nous savons à présent que ce compte, Texas Lone Star,
faisait partie d'une campagne russe de désinformation
qui a été démantelée depuis lors.
Cela change-t-il votre opinion ?
Ça influencerait la mienne
car il s'agit d'une campagne orchestrée
pour semer la zizanie.
Et pour ceux et celles qui pensent
que l'intelligence artificielle va résoudre tous nos problèmes,
Nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire
que le temps où l'IA pourra comprendre ça n'est pas encore venu.
Je vais d'abord vous présenter trois enjeux entrelacés
qui rendent tout ça si compliqué.
Ensuite, je vous proposerai quelques manières de réfléchir à ces défis.
D'abord, notre relation à l'information n'est pas rationnelle,
elle est émotionnelle.
Il n'est pas vrai que davantage de faits vont amender les choses
car les algorithmes déterminent ce que nous voyons,
ils sont conçus pour récompenser nos réactions émotionnelles.
Or, quand on a peur,
les narrations simplifiées à outrance, les théories de conspiration
et les termes qui diabolisent l'autre sont encore plus efficaces.
De surcroît, le modèle de fonctionnement de ces plateformes
est basé sur l'attention.
Ça signifie que leurs algorithmes sont conçus pour favoriser l'émotion.
Ensuite, la plupart des discours que j'évoque sont légaux.
La situation serait différente
si on parlait d'images de pédophilie
ou de contenu incitant à la violence.
Il est parfaitement légal de poster un mensonge patent.
Toutefois, on continue de censurer les contenus problématiques ou nuisibles
sans définition claire de ce que ça signifie.
Mark Zuckerberg n'y échappe pas
quand il plaide en faveur d'une réglementation mondiale des discours.
Je crains que les gouvernements
partout dans le monde
mettent en place des décisions politiques précipitées
qui pourraient en réalité générer des conséquences bien plus graves
en matière d'expression.
Même si nous pouvions décider quels contenus conserver ou éliminer,
nous n'avons jamais eu tant de contenus.
Chaque seconde, des millions de contenus
sont téléchargés partout dans le monde,
dans des langues différentes
et basés sur des contextes culturels multiples.
Nous n'avons aucun mécanisme efficace
pour modérer les discours à cette échelle,
que ce soit avec des humains ou de la technologie.
Troisièmement, ces sociétés, Google, Twitter, Facebook, WhatsApp,
font part d'un écosystème d'information plus vaste.
On a tendance à leur faire porter le blâme mais en fait,
les médias et les représentants politiques peuvent jouer un rôle aussi important
pour amplifier les rumeurs et les conspirations qui les arrangent.
Nous aussi, nous sommes susceptibles de diffuser du contenu trompeur
sans le vouloir.
On accentue la pollution.
Nous cherchons tous un remède miracle.
Mais ça n'existe pas.
Toute solution devra être mise en place à une échelle massive, celle d'Internet,
et les plateformes en fait, sont habituées à cette échelle.
Mais pouvons-nous et devrions-nous les autoriser à gérer ces problèmes ?
Certes, elles essaient.
Nous sommes presque tous d'accord de ne pas souhaiter voir des multinationales
devenir les gardiens de la vérité et de l'équité sur Internet.
Les plateformes seront d'accord aussi, je crois.
Actuellement, elles sont en train de s'accorder des bons points.
Elles nous disent
que leurs interventions sont efficaces.
Mais elles rédigent elles-mêmes leurs rapports sur leur transparence.
Il n'y a donc aucun moyen indépendant pour vérifier les faits.
(Applaudissements)
Pour être franche, la plupart des changements que nous observons
ont lieu après une enquête journalistique
et la mise à nu de preuves de biais
ou de contenus qui enfreignent les règles de fonctionnement.
Bien sûr, ces entreprises doivent jouer un rôle crucial dans le processus
mais elles ne peuvent pas le contrôler.
Qu'en est-il alors des gouvernements ?
Beaucoup fondent leur dernier espoir dans une réglementation mondiale
pour rendre notre écosystème propre.
Mais les politiciens peinent à rester à jour
avec la vélocité de l'évolution technologique.
Pire, ils travaillent dans le noir
car ils n'ont pas accès aux données
pour comprendre ce qu'il se passe sur ces plateformes.
Et puis, en quel gouvernement pourrions-nous faire confiance ?
La réaction doit être mondiale et pas au niveau national.
Le maillon manquant, c'est nous.
Nous, femmes et hommes qui utilisons ces technologies tous les jours.
Saurons-nous concevoir une nouvelle infrastructure
pour véhiculer une information de qualité ?
Je pense que oui.
J'ai quelques idées pour y arriver.
D'abord, si nous sommes déterminés à engager le public,
Wikipedia pourrait être une source d'inspiration.
Ils ont montré que c'est faisable.
Ce n'est pas parfait
mais ils ont démontré qu'avec les structures adéquates,
une vision mondiale et une transparence totale,
on peut construire quelque chose qui gagnera la confiance du public.
Nous devons trouver un moyen de puiser dans la sagesse collective
et l'expérience de tous les utilisateurs,
particulièrement les femmes, les personnes de couleur
et les minorités.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils sont spécialisés dans la haine et la désinformation
dès lors qu'ils sont la cible de ces campagnes depuis si longtemps.
Cela fait des années qu'ils sonnent l'alarme
mais personne ne les écoute.
Cela doit changer.
Est-il possible de construire un Wikipedia de la confiance ?
Comment les utilisateurs pourraient-ils nous nourrir de leurs idées ?
Des idées au sujet des décisions complexes de la modération de contenu.
Un retour quand les plateformes décident de mettre en œuvre des changements.
Ensuite, l'expérience que les gens ont de l'information est personnalisée.
Mon fil de Facebook est différent du vôtre.
Vos recommandations Youtube sont différentes des miennes.
Ceci rend impossible l'analyse en profondeur
des informations vues par les gens.
On pourrait imaginer
de créer une sorte de répertoire ouvert pour les données anonymisées
qui prenne en considération vie privée et éthique.
Imaginez le potentiel de compréhension
issu de la création d'un réseau mondial de citoyens engagés
qui souhaitent faire don de leurs données sociales à la science.
Nous ignorons en effet
les conséquences à long terme de la haine et de la désinformation
sur l'état d'esprit et les comportements.
Et ce que nous en savons
provient d'études réalisées aux États-Unis,
alors que le problème est mondial.
Nous devons aussi remédier à ça.
Troisièmement,
comment relier toutes les parties ?
Aucun secteur seul, encore moins une ONG, une start-up ou un gouvernement
ne pourra résoudre ça.
Mais de nombreuses personnes intelligentes dans le monde
s'attaquent à ces défis dans les salles de rédaction,
la société civile, le monde académique, les communautés activistes.
En voici quelques-uns.
Certains élaborent des indicateurs de crédibilité des contenus.
D'autres vérifient les faits
pour dégrader le taux de référencement des allégations, vidéos et images fausses.
J'ai participé à la création d'une ONG, First Draft,
qui collabore avec des salles de rédaction dans le monde
pour les aider à élaborer des programmes collaboratifs d'investigation.
Dennis Hillis, un programmateur,
conçoit un nouveau système appelé The Underlay,
qui sera l'archive de toutes les déclarations publiques de faits
reliées à leurs sources afin que le public et les algorithmes
puissent mieux évaluer ce qui est crédible.
Des éducateurs dans le monde testent diverses techniques
pour aiguiser l'esprit critique des gens par rapport aux contenus.
Tous ces efforts sont impressionnants mais ils sont dans des silos
et la plupart sont lamentablement sous-financés.
Des centaines de personnes brillantes
travaillent dans ces entreprises
mais à nouveau, leurs efforts ne sont pas consolidés
car ils développent des solutions différentes aux mêmes problèmes.
Comment associer ces personnes
dans un seul lieu physique, pendant quelques jours ou semaines,
pour leur permettre de réfléchir ensemble à ces problèmes
mais avec leur propre perspective ?
Est-ce possible ?
Est-il possible de créer une réponse ambitieuse et coordonnée,
à la hauteur de l'échelle et de la complexité de ce problème ?
J'en suis convaincue.
Ensemble, reconstruisons nos fondations communes de l'information.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)